I do stand behind the decision that ABC
made Sara Gilbert speaks out in her
first TV appearance since ABC cancelled
the rose and revival following star rows
and bars racist remarks she's finally
coming out of her shell quiet everybody
this comes after the actress who played
Darlene one of Roseanne's daughters on
the hit show shared in a Twitter
statement she was disappointed in her TV
moms actions referring to roseanne
calling valerie jarrett former advisor
to president obama and eight in addition
to my statement i would like to say this
has been a very difficult week a lot of
people have been hurt by this and i will
say i'm proud of the show we made the
show
the show has always been about diversity
love and inclusion and it's sad to see
it end in this way I'm sad for the
people who lost their jobs in the
process Gilbert's co-host Sheryl
Underwood also praised her say that
because as a black woman who is a
comedian I'm very very proud of chanting
Dungey who's the president of ABC
Entertainment and as Spike Lee says a
lot of people came together to do the
right thing and I'm happy to see that it
was done swiftly canceling the show so
quickly sent a strong message and the
right message that's for sure
[Applause]